one minute of stuff i've already seen
followed by another 30 seconds of
unnecessary shiny chrome logos
recrap a chrome goes starting your star
wars while orbiting a planetscape cliche
cuddling with cream of offspring soup
also show gives us the how are you even
sleeping all stars featuring child not
in a car seat clutching an aquarium of
your potential offspring and piloting a
spaceship while wearing a heavy helmet
i'm not saying any one of these wouldn't
be possible i'm just saying to calculate
the odds of all three of them happening
at the same time might require
consulting with nate silver
taking the meme lord's name in vain dank
makes the best memes
these tense moments would be much more
concerning if i weren't 100
sure that everyone survives this come up
here i need your hands
wait until you're already plummeting to
ask for assistance granted i'm not
totally aware of how cargo holds work in
this piece of junk but you'd think while
dealing with such precious cargo you
might want to find a better solution
than
vaguely leaning it against the wall
clever needs to stay back
can you do that commando splaining i
just want to point out that someone in
this universe knits sweaters
and somehow these spiky arms move
through the sleeve without tearing up
these perfect cable knit patterns
but seriously how is the child still in
his seat right now
he's not buckled he should be flinging
around the cockpit like a tiny yoda ball
was he born with a heavy case of magnet
ass here we go
nice and easy
seriously you're going to use a walker
type machine in the water
i've seen how clumsy those are you're
one somewhat sturdy piece of trasky and
kelp away from that thing taking a dive
also this is the angle of the ship yet
no one is matched to the interior of the
windshield in comedic fashion
[Music]
amphibio scoop honey
where's liam over there how does he even
know which one
i mean larry lisamander could easily be
gesturing to any number of the buildings
in this direction as there seem to be a
great many options and we already know
mando doesn't speak froggies
this food delivery sphincter reminds me
considering how every planet must have
different food and water how does anyone
manage to travel without spending the
entire first week carbonited to the
toilet
and are toilets across the universe the
same that's a lot of alien butthole
varieties to accommodate
grabbing a man's chowder hose without
explicit consent if yodesh bambino has a
chestburster scene in the next episode
i'm taking back all the sins
or adding all the sins my point is
alien you ever see your mama corey no
but i've seen a papacor make a bad pun
is it anything like that my friend
bought a 10 stroller for his kid from
target and it had those little flip
breaks on the wheels to keep it from
moving and my point is
this thing can freaking levitate so some
sort of breaking apparatus to keep this
from happening shouldn't be a stretch
this car is ours how though even if you
drown him he's enclosed with a mama core
so mamacore eats mando and magically
poops out intact best car
is that the plan
deus ex mandalorian uh also why has
mando pretty much turned into a fuddy
duddy i mean
look at him hanging out above water like
a guy who hasn't leapt into the mouth of
a dragon with a bomb earlier this week
how is he not diving to the bottom of
the boat to retrieve the child right now
he's [ __ ] mando man
he needs no air you do not cover your
face
you are not mandalorian gatekeeping
planets with only one son
you killed my brother now
i'm gonna kill your pet jeez blue mando
group out here deus ex machinating every
five minutes like it's their job
i was hoping you would help me by creed
thing i said to my older brother at a cd
shop in 1997 because i didn't have any
money somehow makes it into the show
little did i know i was building my own
prison i can lead you to one of their
kind
but first we need your help on our
mission what
before mando can move on to the next
part of his quest he needs to take on
another side quest of helping someone
who is also in need of fulfilling their
quest
this is so surprising troopers
and they couldn't hit the side of a
banfa yeah
we know troopers suck at aiming so why
is it ever tough to take anything from
them
why are you waiting for this sneak
attack plan when you could just go take
the ship now
there's nothing you do later with 50
stormtroopers on guard that you couldn't
have done now with a night watch of at
least half that
something's come up treating strangers
like grandparents a full half minute of
star wars spaceship porn
i mean i know this is star wars and
everything but do we have to watch the
entire takeoff routine
none of these troopers even pretend to
see this fog grenade and more
importantly you just wasted a good fog
grenade when they were never going to
hit you anyway
also there were at least 10 of these
morons when the grenade went off but
your heat vision is only picking up four
now
considering your sole purpose was to
hold them off how is this not something
you already did during that lengthy
watching the elevator indicators while
the tension builds cliche
this is more than i signed up for right
but really this entire fight has been
far too easy
and your presence has been largely
unneeded so we're all very disappointed
in this and are gonna need you to mando
up and move on to the boss fight
there is something i need if i am to
rule mandalore something that was once
mine
they know where it is and soon so will i
pronoun gaming your own easter eggs
cool scene and all but you couldn't have
just rolled those things all the way
down that hall from the other side like
you did with the fog grenade earlier
take the found lean to the city of
caledon on the forest planet of corvus
there you'll find ahsoka tano tell her
you were sent by bogotan
okay but who was taking notes cause that
was a lot
thank you for watching him and not
feeding him to your quickly insanely
fast-growing tadpole child
because honestly fair's fair i haven't
seen a vehicle take this much damage and
still find its way back to life since
the herbie movies is this ship going to
develop a personality and do a reboot
with lindsay lohan in a few years called
razor crest fully loaded cause
sin i finally know where i'm taking you
but
it's gonna be a bumpy ride disney could
just cut this line into the end of every
single episode of this show
and i'm not sure anyone would even know
the difference
what is your quest if you've ever wanted
to know what it's like to probe into the
back end of cinema sins and learn our
deepest darkest secrets behind the sins
podcast is just what you need each week
writers aaron that's me today
that's me and jonathan yep discuss what
it takes to create the content that you
enjoy
on youtube hopefully enjoy they probably
do i mean even if they don't we talk
about it that's true i guess i'll just
wrap this up real quick
and let you know that you can listen to
behind the scenes here on youtube
or search for the show on your favorite
podcast player yep almost there
almost there almost there
can you fix it yes we can you've been
captain of the black power for 13 years
technically i was only chem for two
years then i was viciously mutated upon
then you would a pool company but it cut
to nonetheless
you killed my brother prepare to die
now i'm gonna kill your pet and your
little dog
too happy birthday
hey i said my first words